hello freak bitches where I know if you
heard of these guys astrophysicist John
Matisse and Daniel Whitmore from the
University of Louisiana came up with a
theory that said that something smaller
than a Jovian mass would not be strong
enough to perform this task they believe
that there's something up to 25% of them
okay it's four times as big as Jupiter
could be responsible for sending these
objects in our direction geez this is
just a random theory that these guys put
together it wasn't completely accepted
what they did what net no no no there's
no there's no known such object what you
what people are doing and I don't fault
them for it it's creative it would make
awesome science fiction storytelling is
there's something you need to explain
here on earth somebody went extinct
there is some wave of comets there's
some observation that was never repeated
there's some thing you got to come up
with and so you say well we know the
Oort cloud exists we know you can
perturb those orbits and and send them
careening down towards the inner solar
system and those that Jupiter doesn't
bat away like batting practice those
that get through Jupiter's gravitational
shield could wreak havoc on earth yeah
yeah but that's it's it's it's it's
inventing a lot to explain something you
don't know
right so it's inventing more of what you
don't know that could be true to explain
what you don't right that which you
don't have any other evidence to support
so it's fun speculation fun speculation
but beyond that to say oh it's real it
must be happening no no it's just let
someone write a good sci-fi story on it
here's what's fun about it and this is
why I bring it up most people I've
talked to this about the subject to many
many people and I myself personally I'm
not immune to this I find it very
fascinating however how much have I
looked into the actual planets that we
absolutely know a real not that much but
I'm worried about this fucking fake
planet that may or may not exist do they
might have found another planet it's
this idea of something hidden and
mysterious which is so compelling and
attractive that's a fascinating
psychological observation it's a weird
thing we want to believe there's
something miss
Styria isn't it we don't understand and
could be there but we don't know
anything about yet where there's plenty
of things we do know something about but
we want to know more why don't you help
yes all right
and by the way the universe is far more
wondrous than anything we can imagine
and so so to say I need your creativity
and you know to keep your life
interesting no we got black holes that
are slaying stars layer by layer we've
got do you realize that if you fall into
a black hole you will see the entire
future of the universe unfold in front
of you in a matter of moments and you
will emerge into another space-time
created by the singularity of the black
hole you just fell into you just broke
the air after you grow up the Holga and
everything so so let's talk about that
all right yeah you know why are we
wasting time talking about whether the
Saturn 5 rocket I mean because we're
fascinated by shit that's unproven look
mysterious shit look I got a broken
brain ok there's a reason for me